all right joining me now is the man
launching that investigation house
oversight committee chair James Comer
Congressman good to see you
uh listen I want to see you I want to
get your take on on this because uh we
reached out to Mayor Pete for a comment
and we were actually referred to this
tweet that says I'm alarmed to learn
that the chair of the house oversight
committee thinks that the NTSB is part
of our department NTSB is an independent
and with good as independent and with
good reason still of course we will
fully review and respond appropriately
Congressman how to respond to Mayor
Pete's ridiculous tweet
what he referred to as a typo in the
letter that had absolutely nothing to do
but with what we were requesting from
mayor Pete we want to know the response
from the Secretary of Transportation the
people in this community in Ohio are
concerned no one from the federal
government seemed to express an interest
in their well-being no one at high
levels of the government and we want to
know what communication took place uh
who made what decision based on burning
the chemicals how do we know who's
coordinating with the EPA and other and
and other emergency agencies that will
ensure that groundwater is not
contaminated we just have a lot of
questions in this Administration has
been too busy to provide answers for the
American people the president is out in
Ukraine promising more tax dollars to to
Ukraine to protect their border when our
borders unsecure and the Secretary of
Transportation has had personal time he
hasn't had time to go out there so we
want to know exactly who's in charge and
what decisions were made and when they
were made you know not only for this
train derailment but maybe we want to
hear about what happened with the FAA or
with a supply chain or with baby formula
or with Southwest over Christmas do you
think you're going to get a response
from you know mayor Pete after that
flipping text or tweet I should say
well you know that just shows the
arrogance and the tone deafness of this
Administration we have a lot of concerns
with what's going on in the
transportation cabinet we have Airline
delays uh we're having rail disasters uh
we have an infrastructure crisis the
federal government just invested a
significant amount of money and
infrastructure and all we've heard from
the Secretary of Transportation is that
the infrastructure is racist and that
there are too many white people that are
going to be working in these
construction jobs I mean this isn't the
type of leadership that I think the
American people expect from the
Secretary of Transportation so we have a
lot of questions for mayor Pete and
hopefully he's going to Cave to public
pressure and start providing us with
answers this is the oversight committee
we're not going to let up just because
the Democrat turned a blind eye to
providing any type of oversight of the
buy Administration for the first two
years that's over now the Republicans
are in the majority we have questions
that the American people deserve answers
for and if he doesn't why I hope you
reduce the funding of his department but
I want to move on because uh you have
some news for us in the investigation
into Hunter Biden in the laptop Joe
Biden
yeah we do uh obviously we're requesting
information from all the stakeholders
that were involved in the various
different Biden family influence
peddling schemes and we're glad that
people are now coming forward obviously
the Biden family isn't but that doesn't
matter at this particular point in time
because there are so many people that
were affiliated with the Biden that have
information that we need to go along
with the bank records that we will get
and I think that we're going to be able
to trace the money back to the sources
the sources in China the sources in
Ukraine and the sources in Russia and
hopefully we can get answers for what
did the Biden family do to receive this
much money millions and millions of
dollars coming from China Russia and
Ukraine for services that we're not sure
exactly what they were this could put
this Administration in a compromised
position with our adversaries that's why
we're investigating you know Congressman
the FBI should be doing a forensic
article audit of Joe Biden that would
make it real easy it shouldn't be your
job to do what the FBI's actual role is
here but just you know real quick
um will you subpoena Hunter Biden he
just missed a deadline to turn over
documents to your committee
we're making sure every eye's dotted and
every cheese crossed as you know you can
subpoena people then it goes to court if
they don't comply with the subpoena
we're going to make sure when we issue
subpoenas
that they're going to hold up in court
now in the meantime we're going to
continue to request information for the
bidens but luckily for our investigation
other people are coming forward so we've
got plenty of information to digest now
we're doing that and I can tell you this
is a serious investigation and the
American people should be very concerned
about why the bidens receive so much
money from the Chinese Communist Party
linked uh that's right Affiliates in
China Congress Congressman coma we're
looking forward to the answers that your
committee can provide the American
people thank you for joining me tonight
and thanks for all your hard work hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else